bonjour à vous merci d'avoir accepté de
réagir en direct sur rt france alors
l'immunité donc parlementaires de
plusieurs députés pro soro élevée quelle
est votre réaction
bien bonjour les minutes et le vélo de
lapin ou double nous pensons pas que
l'immunité soit levé et ça c'est la
position donc de 2,2 gps tout simplement
parce que ce qui a été fait n'est pas
conforme à la loi tout simplement la
position des gps électeurs depuis le
début nous sommes face à un véritable
offert nous sommes face à un véritable à
la ville-etat mise en place d'un état de
non droit en côte d'ivoire où des
décisions se prennent non conforme ni à
la constitution ni aux lois qui
régissent notre pays alors on précise
entre le 23 et le 31 décembre 17 membres
de l'entourage de guillaume soro dont
cinq députés ont été arrêtés et écroués
quelles sont les informations dont vous
disposez quelle est leur situation en
côte d'ivoire
les informations que nous recevons en
fait il n'y a aucune information
officielle
on accuse le député les personnes les
quinze personnes qui ont été arrêtés le
23 décembre d'avoir été pris en flagrant
délit jusqu'à ce jour les avocats n'ont
pas accès à ce dossier on ne sait pas
exactement quel est le daily caller
reproche ensuite
par rapport à leur situation ils ont été
transférés sur ordre du ministère de la
justice alors que selon leurs propres
c'est dur le dossier était à
l'instruction devant un juge ce qui est
donc illégal ils ont été séparés sous
prétexte qu'il ya une surpopulation
carcérale à la prison d'abidjan
et pourtant des prisonniers les
consignes d'y aller et donc mes mots
justes à l'heure où je vous parle la
décision du juge de gaza de la cour de
cassation de se saisir du dossier n'a
pas été transmise au tribunal de
première instance d'abidjan donc nous
sommes en fait dans une situation nous
observons et loue le gouvernement ait
rajouté paix et la justice en côte
d'ivoire fait ce que bon lui semble
alors il ya plusieurs procédures à
l'encontre de guillaume soro mais aussi
des députés donc qui le soutiennent
guillaume soro il est concerné par une
procédure pour recel de détournement de
deniers publics et blanchiment de
capitaux notamment un autre député pro
soro alain lobognon lui et il a été
arrêté on lui reproche donc une atteinte
notamment la sûreté de l'état
qu'est ce que vous pouvez nous dire sur
justement ces procédures et ses
accusations voilà bien soro était
premier ministre en 2007 2008 lorsqu on
lui reproche d'avoir acquis une maison
où sa résidence de
de marcory donc c'est la décision donc
le procureur a lancé qu'une information
judiciaire était ouverte là dessus en
fait comme je le dis depuis toujours dit
on serait justiciable comme tout le
monde mais maintenant ni dans la forme
ni dans le fond cette affaire ne peut
pas espérer dans la forme il était
premier ministre à l'époque des faits et
donc le procureur de la république il
veut même pas une tente et union bourg
une information judiciaire concernant
concernant cette affaire
quant au député alain lobognon qui
ancien membre du gouvernement également
sa détention en prison est un non sens
et l'enseignement du gouvernement notre
constitution et la loi surtout de 2005
portant statut des enseignements du
gouvernement issus d'institutions elle
éclaire la haute cour de justice pour
les juger en tout cas yens procédure
porte concernant le premier ministre et
l'ancien chef d'état de l'assemblée
nationale qui en sort
concernant la ceinture de bruxelles
ancien membre de gouvernement allait
lobognon également une star une
procédure spéciale qui existent pour
pouvoir les juger
malheureusement comme je l'expliqué tout
à l'heure en côte d'ivoire en fait les
lois les textes existent et qui sont
appliqués à géométrie variable selon
qu'on soit de l'opposition au pas le but
en finale et toute cette manoeuvre est
simple c'est d'écarter un candidat
sérieux à l'élection présidentielle du
31 octobre 2020 et de décapiter le
mouvement qui va mis en place parce que
simplement il a refusé d'adhérer au
parti au pouvoir rapidement
guillaume soro vous l'avez dit les
candidats donc à cette présidentielle
considéré comme un favori par bon nombre
d'observateurs mais il a lancé un appel
à la résistance notamment depuis
l'europe où il parcourt le continent
européen notamment en vue de sa campagne
présidentielle
comment est-ce qu'il faut interpréter
cet appel est ce que justement ce n'est
pas de nature à faire peur
pouvoir ivoirien actuel le pouvoir
devrait avoir peur de corps l'appel que
qui sera lancé cet appel à la résistance
pacifique et politique
il a été clair là dessus le gps continue
d'oeuvrer sur le terrain nous continuons
même si les locaux des gps ont été
saccagées ont été vandalisés par des
hommes en tenue
même si le matériel des gps dans ses
locaux a été pris par ces hommes là sans
aucun mandat de perquisition et sans que
l'on comprenne pourquoi
le gps continue de fonctionner et donc
on ne peut pas à la fois revenir et
continuer d'agir de façon politique et
de consigne de mobiliser les personnes
en vue de ces élections là et puis avoir
d'autres desseins par derrière la tête
non soyons sérieux
guillaume soro a lancé son mouvement et
si vous voyez que aujourd'hui tour les
leaders de ce mouvement là sont détenus
cela faisait la raison est simple c'est
parce que le gps rapeurs rockers hdp et
que le rhdp a décidé justement de tout
faire pour que notre visiteur aucun
mouvement pour gt on sera sur le terrain
mais les ivoiriens auront leur destin en
main en 2020 et guillaume soro candidat
va se présenter et les ivoiriens le
peuple souverain de côte d'ivoire
choisira son président pour cette
élection et nous sommes convaincus que
ce sera grand saut merci beaucoup à vie
mme sanogo porte-parole de la cellule
europe de gps génération et peuples
solidaires merci à vous